which one is the authentic prophet
is it the fellow who vaguely states that
someday humans will become extinct
or is it the fellow who
more precisely states that on the 1st of
march of the year 2030
the last human will die
is a prediction the same thing as a
prophecy
more fundamental yet
does predicting play any role whatsoever
in science
[Music]
the mathematical establishment regards
predictions to be an integral part of
science
the reason for this is not a mystery
describe is all that mathematics is
capable of or authorized to do
and without an explanation to support it
a prediction is just a description
a car is traveling at 50 miles per hour
the mathematician can predict that it
will be 50 miles away from origin if it
travels on a rectal linear path
even if the prediction materializes all
that the mathematician has done is
describe what's going to happen
the dictionary defines prediction as
a statement about a future event often
based upon experience or knowledge
in a previous video we showed that
knowledge is nothing more than a synonym
of belief
but does prediction require that the
fortune teller base it on experience
an element that patently invokes the
past
the prophet predicts that haley's
comment will arrive in our cosmic
neighborhood in the year 2061.
so far all we have is a description
the soothsayer has yet to state a cause
that will trigger the phenomenon
but what if the astrologer clarifies
that haley's comment returns every 75
years
this periodicity is certainly based on
experience but we still have nothing
more than a description
we have no idea what causes the comet to
circle the sun
is science about predicting that if i
let go of the pen
it will fall to the floor rather than to
the ceiling
is science about predicting
the rate at which
the pen will fall to the floor
because i have measured this a million
times
or is science about explaining
what causes the pen to fall to the floor
anyone can make an open-ended prediction
and guess that humans will become
extinct someday
it is a little harder to give a precise
date when this event will occur
but hopefully science is about neither
science should be objective so that the
listener understands
hopefully
science about explaining the mechanism
that will cause the extinction of man
[Music]